décembre dans nos sociétés modernes où
l'individualisme à la part belle les
initiatives suivantes et est
intéressante car elle plaide pour une
plus grande fraternité je veux parler de
l'opération immeubles en fête organisée
cette année dans plus de 200 villes hier
soir dans la banlieue de grenoble le
reportage de marina bay chai et canal
copie voyait les chefs et là il ya des
ballons d'essai l'on voulait montrer
tout le monde s'y est mis pour que la
fête soit réussie des ballons des gaza
un cocktail pour une fête de quartier en
bonne harmonie
on se retrouve ne serait ce que pour un
échange culinaire
moi je pense que c'est un partage en
même temps que des mamans qui sont
peut-être de nationalités différentes
des gens complètement différente
d'attitude ou autres peuvent vraiment se
retrouver pour partager un moment
convivial en mangeant et pourtant ce
mélange des genres n'était pas gagné
d'avancé
nous sommes dans la banlieue de grenoble
ici se côtoient hlm et immeubles en
copropriété
il y a deux ans un mur a bien failli
séparer les deux et isolé les habitants
de la copropriété de ceux des hlm
après sentiment général c'était ce
samedi l'autorisation qui s'annonce
excellent cette clôture même si elle
n'était pas pas comme au départ où il
avait été question d'un mur puis c'était
petit à petit a qu'à discussion ça
c'était ramenait un mur est surmonté
d'une d'un grillage mais c'est d'élever
le principe le principe de séparer
aujourd'hui chacun a refait l'histoire à
sa manière mais il n'est plus question
du mur à la fête des voisins hier il y
avait une centaine de personnes des hlm
et de la copropriété
tous réunis autour d'un kiosque qu'ils
ont pas ensemble après s'être engagé
dans une charte à se respecter
mutuellement
c'est surtout une charte d'engagements
communs donc on n'a pas demandé
seulement les habitants n'ont pas dit
nous habitons on s'engage tout le monde
s'engage parce qu'on est tous
partenaires et dans cette charte de
voisinage qui est intéressant c'est le
partenariat l'an dernier ce quartier a
même gagné le prix d'immeubles en fête
pour la fête la plus réussie la plus
fédératrice
il y a deux ans encore personne n'aurait
parié sur cette bonne entente
aujourd'hui les habitants même l'idée de
multiplier les fêtes de voisinage toute
l'année cette fois